hey guys I'm out of the country at the
moment but we didn't want to leave you
with no clips so here's some perfect BS
from CNN for the kids I mean in
retrospect in hindsight now that the
smoke has cleared
do you regret not pressing for full
um school full in-person School sooner I
regret covid and I regret that we didn't
know
um sooner
um what was he to keeping people safe
and keeping schools open both of those
things were really important I had many
members who died in the first few months
in terms of covet we had members die in
New York City we had many people who got
really really sick and black and brown
folks got more sick than white folks so
what we were trying to figure out was
how to reopen schools and how to do it
safely and the problem is that you
already have in City Schools bad
conditions that are hot that are hard
for teachers to teach in and what we're
trying to do was make sure that they and
families were safe
foreign foreign foreign